h-huh Wow
look at selection click the right Oh
got it
Hey look at me I'm running everybody
don't mind me just walking down the
street now the probable make me chase
you don't make me chase you out I'm
gonna getcha stop right there
oh good you think you're here Oh got you
now [ __ ]
oh no where am I my look oh it's me
we've got the place no no no please grow
up hold the grip or tribute to make a
fist
Oh punch by extending your arm making
contact when opening appears right click
okay
you can also slap an opponent with an
open hand block by raising your arms
what are you doing
how okay buta for big I see how it is
you got nice stop every time all right
all right
Oh God
how you doing Wendell your parole
officers feeling lonely he's got a hole
in his life for NASA he's got you you
got a whole thing going when your pants
snap-on watch your head watch this hole
back in the iron down nice work oh I
know you run track in high school no but
I ran the slap Club we slap [ __ ] all
the time what is this oh yeah one minute
get in the tank
excuse me I don't even have a driving
license well I guess I better get in the
cab
we'll take that only a couple blocks
from here
alright 14 Adam calling kgp l will
handle the 211 don't be scared don't be
scanned
Roger kg PL 14 Adam enroute are you
scared are you take the next right I
will I will take the next one where you
talk to me like that again and you will
face the same take the next right
what okay
don't worry let's go
Oh
sorry
the next clap whoa
next left guarding
do you fear it through the next
intersect now tell me something that you
fear dying
are you standing dying through the
no you did not just do that I didn't do
nothing you're stressing me out man I am
trying to drive like a perfect gentleman
oh [ __ ] it's a robbery oh god I'm scared
I've never done this skipper I don't
know what I thought would happen stay
down stay down [ __ ] what do I do I'm so
scared my power move stay in cover what
the [ __ ] is it what are you doing moving
in I'm movin in guys don't [ __ ] tell
me what to do
he fell for the old hay trick laptop
yeah that's what I'm talking about
what's going on over here hey Johnny I
think I found a clue crawl a kill
insects brain maybe
excuse me workers please step aside
we're basically working this is spooky
I'm super scared right now
Jesus Cole come take a look at the I see
it dude I see her put him up against the
wall and whose brains out damnable way
to go dude I don't know about this blood
matter how you go this is this is a bit
scary Oh get all deep only built let's
keep going two rounds fired and instead
of dropping it down a drain our shooter
voices it up here interesting guy we
should follow up on this now before the
perp tries to leave town it's fired
twice yes I see I'll draw I'll draw a
picture of the gun Hey just Phelps
undone can you tell us anything about
this gun Smith & Wesson Model 27
registered Magnum chambered for 357 Hey
they complete it with programs same gun
used by General Patton you're not
suggesting he's the owner no no no no
you seem to know a lot about your weapon
let me do the talking sold it you know
this piece will stop a rhino these
babies oh my god that's a special order
here's my Smith & Wesson order book okay
let's see here
pearl grips cold you see it on a real
collectors I don't like your attitude
sorry I can't help you more hey we're in
luck
Errol Schroeder 203 southwest street
ordered the gun in February 46
thanks you've been a big help any time
thank you very much happy to help out
the LAPD you're doing a great job thank
you I really my affair but I hope you
catch whoever you're looking for are
these authentic are these authentic
ducks how much how much for them
please oh my god okay oh sorry
that wasn't me I swear stop that stop
that you [ __ ] [ __ ] you you hey you
hey you do you know shredding here's his
phone number don't make me is that milk
now I haven't had a nice bottle of milk
and forever
judge open up its the popo what are you
guys whoa hey I'm officer Cole Phelps
don't mind me Verdun [ __ ] division
you're the owner of a Smith & Wesson
Model 27 nickel-plated with pearl grips
I might be what of it then you'll be
surprised to know that scooter Payton
was murdered tonight with your gun
you're out of your mind
scooter he works for me they have that
gun here in my drawer
you're under arrest Schroeder come in my
way you're not taking me down for this
oh oh it's very sad
no it's sound again Oh sweetie slap
maced
come wake up come come I said oh you got
you're gonna cry huh you gonna crap
you're gonna crack you're gonna cry are
you gonna crack
this is how a fire in Sweden this is how
the Vikings fire oh my god
LAPD LAPD cleared the body please please
has anyone called an ambulance we've
called an ambulance and the police but
I'm afraid he's dead what did you see
the [ __ ] up oh don't make me hey hey
look at this look at this
don't make me now tell me what you saw I
got nothing on this guy
hey hey mama hey mama don't worry don't
worry
it's gonna be okay huh then just tell me
what you suppose yeah no I'm not gonna
like you're probably gonna go many years
enterprise are you just staring at me
like that because I mean nothing wrong
oh yes what you think you have your can
I go to jail
you're gonna go to jail you're gonna go
in for a very long but don't worry don't
worry
if Papa boots can get one of those
shoots in size 42 hey why are you just
staring at me like not worried
I've done nothing I'm officer Phelps
miss I'm here about the shooting I'm
here about the show do you know the
victim - it wasn't my boss yes don't
worry it's mr. gage not mr. Burrage
don't you are I was in a store when mr.
gage my boss bursts in yelling that I'm
late on my lunch and we came back I was
angry I walked in front yes of course I
heard shots mm-hmm I turned and saw mr.
gage fall oh nice
that's awful
and don't know who shot gage or why no
officer that's truth my man is dead miss
: and that's a criminal offense to lie
to a police officer I'll take you
downtown get out get out right now
alright check the dumpster look at that
huh you didn't see are you kidding me
any ideas looks like there's something
in this trash can I already found it
operator give me dispatch Phelps badge
12 47 messages please thanks for your
help I grabbed the gun right you think
something would happen
but nothing happens this is glitched
outer wake-up call
I found shell casings he's looked like
thirty twos
oh so now I found a gun okay I get it no
I guess the gun still isn't interesting
got it
let's go
he's fine don't worry about him I want
you to know that I loved you
I really thought we would be together
forever you were always my brother hey
wait no no no don't go back there Baldy
you forgot your hat oh oh how did I not
come over you can just run into people
so sorry so sorry so sorry so sorry
Hey